the expanse takes a small step closer to
its return as a comic book breaks all
records welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV movie channel
[Music]
so I know what you're going to ask what
on Earth does a comic book have to do
with the return of the expanse well if
you are a regular site tracker you'll
know that after the expanse season 6
ended at wamazam I told you that
actually a couple of companies were very
interested to take up the project if
Amazon decided not to we know that there
are still three novels in the series
that they could base a series on but
Amazon currently have chosen not to now
amkron is the company that actually owns
the intellectual property that is the
expanse they actually own the TV show
they're the people that actually made it
they made it for Netflix they made it
for the Sci-Fi channel and they made it
for Amazon
but they do not hold the distribution
rights Amazon do and the contracts that
amcon signed stated that Amazon had two
years following the end of any
production to actually hold on to those
rights so at the end of two years if
Amazon decide not to take up the option
to produce more of the expanse amcon are
allowed to sell it to somebody else now
I told you that initially HBO Max and
Warner Brothers were the company most
interested but that interest has
weighing somewhat since David zasloff
have come in ETC they are focusing on a
much smaller pot of TV shows and things
and they're not as interested as they
once were but that does not mean that
the interest went away Apple stepped in
and they would be very interested in
creating something around the expanse
Universe now something I did tell you
that that very early on after the end of
season six Amazon did consider
continuing the project they did consider
making three movies at one point they
then considered maybe doing a spin-off
show but none of these things got past
sort of the initial conversation stage
and really have been stuck as far as I'm
aware from my sources in and around
Amazon no further conversations have
happened they're focusing on other
things so amcon have about a year left
until they could potentially sell this
to Apple that they could make a new
television series and put it on Apple TV
plus but what would Apple like them to
make well apparently HBO and apple kind
of agreed on this they don't necessarily
want to jump straight into season seven
what they would quite like to do is
create something that is their own they
want to build a franchise off this
universe if possible now franchises are
going to be something new here a lot
about in this channel in the next few
months because it seems to be an
obsession particularly your streaming
services about building franchises they
become very aware that anything with the
Star Wars words on it sell and that they
want to have similar sort of projects in
their stable now Apple desperately want
a big serious sci-fi project dragon's
tooth is going to be the next comic book
produced by James S.A Corey as the
Creator Andy diggle as one of the
writers and Rubin as the main artist
they're going to produce this comic book
and they've done it through boom Studios
now they set up a Kickstarter project
with a target of 25
000 if they met that Target they would
be able to produce the comic you were
basically pre-ordering the comic by
signing up to the kickstart in the first
24 hours they go below past 25 000 and
actually reached a grandson total of 179
251 they then smashed any record for a
Kickstart within the first day one week
into this and they're currently at 827
802 and there's still a couple of weeks
to go so it would seem that this comic
book is 100 going to happen but also
this underlines and again proves the
popularity of the expanse this is the
most grown up of all of the Sci-Fi we've
seen in the last probably 10 years
it's the most realistic sci-fi we've
seen the last 10 years and the fans of
the expanse are absolutely committed to
the series and would love to see it
return
so what does the comic book success mean
to the Future well it should also be
noted that the comic book is based
immediately after book six but before
book Seven it is a spin-off it is
exactly the sort of story that Apple
want it is exactly the sort of story
that HBO Max were asking about
so essay Corey was obviously very aware
of this again exclusively on Sidetrack I
told you a couple of months ago actually
that now in Shankar and Ty Frank
producers from the original series were
currently going through the process of
creating their own production company
now this again might be two plus two
equals six a little bit but the creators
of the original show are trying to make
a production company the writer from the
original show James sa Cory is writing
and creating a comic book based on the
things that we know the big streamer
Services asked for a story between six
and seven they seem to be trying to
create a wider universe and a bigger
story a franchise opportunity for a
bigger story exactly again what the
streaming services are asking for so
assuming that Amazon in the next 12
months doesn't have a massive change of
heart and change direction it does look
like we're going to see the expanse once
more but on a completely different
Channel again and that that new series
will be something we have not seen it
will not be based on book Seven but
based on some of the more interesting
possibilities that we were left with at
the end of book six now guys get into
comments and tell me exactly what you
think but I think I know what I'm going
to get told and there are lots of really
interesting battles and struggles for
them to explore in lots of different
ways that any spin-off series can do
if the expanse returns to Apple TV plus
I'm gonna have to go and subscribe and
that's another big reason why Apple
desperately want to because they know
loads of fans of the expanse will follow
I cannot wait to see if these plans pan
out and if they do we could get to see
some really really exciting very
different stories something very
different to static very different to
Star Wars grown-up sci-fi for grown-ups
and that's really what we want to see so
guys get to the comments tell me exactly
what you think is the expanse something
you desperately want to return I would
love to know as a bit of a poll if the
expanse did end up on Apple TV plus
would you subscribe
I'd love to know exactly what you think
get into the comments if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe by the
Bell notification and if you want to
become a fully fled side tracker and
support the channel even more consider
hitting that join button also check out
the description there's loads of links
to loads of Sidetrack stuff
click that Discord server Twitter
account blah blah blah blah
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
[Music]